there isn't anything that you can
possibly do that makes you more
competent in everything you do than to
learn how to communicate nobody is going
to care or listen to you and the very
nature of influence and impact which is
the leaders job is communication
rise and shine it's an expresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message develop your
communication skills over to you Jordan
B Peterson also if you want to know what
Jordan B Peterson and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below if you're gonna
speak effectively you have to know way
more than you're talking about
I'm incredibly nervous to talk in front
of you because you've got to be one of
the most formidable people that I've
ever heard up or ever listened to her
ever seen so my question is again you're
one of the best communicators that I've
ever listened to if I could be half as
good at you or at communicating as you
are I would be set how can I teach
myself to do that practice you know
really like well there's a couple of
things is helps to read a lot it really
helped to write so if you want to make
yourself articulate which is a very good
idea then not only should you read but
you should write down what you think and
if you can do that a little bit every
day 15 minutes maybe you could steal 15
minutes and do it every day but if you
do that for 10 years
you really straighten out your thinking
if you're gonna speak effectively you
have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
ten times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can specify a
stepping path through it and elaborate
with the other things that you know but
to do that you have to do a lot of
reading but you also have to do a lot of
reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes so that's on the input side and
then on the output side well there's
some tricks techniques let's say like if
you're speaking in front of a group you
are not delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group there's a
bunch of individuals and you talk to
them so when I talk to a group I always
talk to people one at a time and that
makes it easier too because you know how
to talk to a person it's like can you
talk to a thousand people well probably
not because it's too intimidating but
there isn't a thousand people there
there's a thousand individuals and so
you just look at an individual and you
say something and you can tell if
they're engaged they look confused or
they look interested or they look angry
or they look bored or maybe they're
asleep in which case you look at someone
else and they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so one thing is to
to have something to say yeah but the
next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but at first but on
first sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural wealth of
social skill will manifest itself is
extremely high and so you don't deliver
a talk to an audience that's a really
bad way of thinking about you're
actually engaged in a conversation with
an audience even if they're not talking
they're nodding and shifting position
and you know looking like this or and
you can you can pull all that in and and
and use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could bunch us that to some degree well
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do then
to learn how to communicate I don't care
if you're gonna be a carpenter I mean
being a carpenter by the way is very
difficult especially if you're a good
carpenter but if you're good at
communicating as a carpenter you're like
ten times better as a carpenter so the
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges I think and I don't know
if they've forgotten it but they don't
do a very good job of marketing it's
like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
you've read something it's like the
economic value that is incalculable the
people that I've watched in my life
would be spectacular ly successful are
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're really good negotiator everybody
walks away from the negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you so and that's all that's all
dependent on your ability to communicate
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have and I think a lot of businesses
fail because the entrepreneur cannot
communicate well and if they even are
sharing their ideas they are not
convincing enough and so a lot of great
ideas die you could have the next
greatest idea that can change the world
it's sitting up here but because you
can't articulate it because you can't
share it because you can't communicate
it well because you're not convincing
enough to the people around you it will
never take off the idea will die within
you and I hate that I hate that because
building a business getting the thing
that's out here out into the world is
greater than one person no matter how
much of a genius you are to build a
business you need a team you need a team
of people to help you go far and you
also need to convince the media and
customers and partners and suppliers of
what you have is amazing if you are the
only one who thinks that your idea is
amazing and you can't communicate or
convince anybody else of that then
you're done the night idea dies within
you and I think unfortunately that's a
lot of entrepreneurs so Jordan has three
of his tips I'm gonna give you three of
mine on how to be a convincing
communicator step number one is have a
powerful opinion you have an opinion
what is it that you are trying to say
make it mean something to yourself
and to me and make that the first
sentence
every piece of content that you make if
you're doing a video that's your first
sentence you're doing an Instagram post
put it in there you're doing a LinkedIn
post an email a newsletter like put it
in there you lead with your powerful
opinion on what is wrong with the world
or what your viewpoint on XYZ topic is
make it mean something to me make me
care so if I'm talking about
communication how important it is for
entrepreneurs a powerful opinion would
be something like you need to learn how
to communicate in your business or you
will never get that idea that's in your
head out into the world and your idea
will die inside you that's an opinion
where lots of people might say something
like so if you want to learn how to
build a successful business and maybe
take your idea to the next level I think
maybe you should focus on trying to
improve how you speak and communicate
like it's so long it has lots of filler
words you use words like maybe and
potentially and someday and one day and
I wish and we instead of I like
affirmative stop worrying about what
people's reactions are gonna be and
speak your truth always lead with a
powerful opinion tip number two is
emotional commitment this is where a lot
of entrepreneurs really fall down you've
got your pals of opinion you know what
you stand for you know what you're
trying to communicate but when you get
in front of a camera or when you get
down to writing it doesn't sway people
it's not emotional enough you could be
saying all the best words when you get
in front of a camera to make a video but
because you are talking in a very boring
very non exciting manner and because
you're so worried about saying the
perfect words that you are memorizing
something or you are looking at your
script or trying to read from a
teleprompter nobody is going to care or
listen to you you need to have emotional
commitment you need to feel the thing
and how important it is while you are
saying it for me I'm envisioning all of
you I'm envisioning all the
entrepreneurs that I've worked with who
have these amazing ideas and they never
get
because they can't communicate and even
though I'm sitting here in an office by
myself and there's nobody around to
actually connect with I'm just talking
to a camera I'm trying to channel you
I'm trying to channel all the people
that I've connected with and seen and I
want to make sure that your business
does well and communicating is so
important as part of that which is why
I'm doing this video and hopefully the
care the love the energy comes through
in the content that I make and so sales
and convincing people not enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something that you guys can
get together on is about the energy
transfer you are not just selling a
concept or an idea you are transferring
energy whoever is more confident wins
whoever is more convincing wins and it's
usually from whoever believes in their
thing more if you absolutely believe in
your thing and that this is right and
it's for them when they need to do this
thing because it's in their best
interest not because you're just trying
to sell something down their throat but
you really really really really care and
if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying that's how
you bring them on board it's great to
have the best words but more important
is the emotional commitment that you
have behind them so the best test with
any of this is watch back some of your
content and watch back your videos read
your newsletters see the copy on your
website look at the story that you wrote
about yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom boom like
yes that's right that's why I do this
thing or do you watch it and you get
bored if you get bored and it doesn't
get your heart beating then do it again
do it again and do it again and do it
again and do it again you will be one of
your best critics you will be one of
your harshest critics and so we know if
you look over your content and get to
the point where you say wow yeah I'm
really proud of that that's when you
start to win and tip number three is
raise the stakes just make it more
important if you want to move people so
often we're focused just on the tactics
the strategies here's the five things
that you need to do and people say yeah
yeah yeah great I love those the five
things
they write them down and then they never
do anything about it you need to raise
the stakes you have to make it more
important you have to make me feel the
pressure that if I don't do this thing
that you want me to do terrible things
will happen right so if I talk about how
important communication is me just
saying communication is really important
as an entrepreneur here are the three
ways to do it it's not as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you don't learn how
to communicate your idea and get it out
there that idea will die inside you and
your mission will never be realized and
listen that paints a dark picture that's
going to an extreme and the idea is not
to have hyperbole and make things bigger
than they are
but that's a real case for tons of
entrepreneurs that if they do not learn
how to communicate properly their ideas
will never get out there and their idea
will die inside them and so your goal if
you want to move people is to make them
realize how big this thing is for them
if they don't take action you're the
expert you know where the road is going
you see their future if they continue
down that path they don't see that
future they don't understand it it's
your job to help them see where this
current path of action is gonna lead
them and if they make the tweak they
make the change to take your
recommendations where it could go raise
the stakes make it more important make
them feel that it's more important and
it actually starts with you feeling that
this message is insanely important now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but for
that question the day I want to know
what is one powerful opinion that you
have I want to actually start taking
some action I want you to practice write
down one sentence a powerful opinion
make it mean something make it matter to
you raise the stakes make it more
important tell me what's gonna happen if
I don't go off and pay attention to your
message
write down that one sentence this is
practice time put it down the comments
below I look forward to seeing what you
have to say
most leaders most businesspeople most
entrepreneurs most human beings have
never learned to be masterful
communicators and the very nature of
influence and impact which is the
leaders job is communication I mean in
school were you given a communication
course very few people have been taught
that in your personal relationships have
you read books on communication well
that leads to I mean in in an intimate
relationship or even just with a friend
it's the little miscommunications that
over time stack into loss in your
intimate relationships it's the little
conversations that you could have had in
five minutes if you have the tools to
communicate and the awareness to speak
so literally you could release the anger
and build understanding and speak out
your needs and feel the need to be heard
all those little things if you had
learned how to do that over and done it
in five minutes with your intimate
partner you might not have lost the
relationship and in your professional
life learning to communicate inspires
your teammates you know if you look at
the great leaders of humanity the Nelson
Mandela's the mother Teresa the Martin
Luther King Junior's the john f
kennedy's if you look at the great
business builders Steve Jobs great
example right he would be on the stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing and that's
when he would reveal the latest piece of
technology that would create industry
dominance when Steve Jobs was at Apple
well he was a masterful communicator and
Bud Tribble over at Apple called it his
reality distortion field Steve Jobs was
a master salesman he knew exactly what
to say to get people to believe in the
impossible
to allow their I can't to be less
valuable than their I can't raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion can change not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
supposed to mean if you want to learn
more from Jordan Peterson on how to stop
procrastinating and increase your
productivity check out the video next to
me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I probably plan each minute and
yes it leads to way higher productivity